one good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy uh what is it
Thursday oh is that great thank god oh
and it's an even better Thursday because
this sexy piece of ass has joined me in
studio today it's true hey sexy piece of
ass how you doing I'm doing great sexy
peace ass how you doing I'm darn good
it's my husband the one and only been
software boy with no job host of the
good guys podcast founder of spirit
Society how you doing it's a pretty good
like list you know yeah founder of
sports Society host some good guys
podcast best friend to host of the toast
podcast Butler
to host of the toast podcast Butler to
host of the toast podcast masseuse to
host of the toast podcast love her lover
hey sexy how you doing darling I'm doing
great I was just complaining to you that
I'm a little bit sore yeah no and I I
can't I never grow tired of hearing you
complain it's our love language I don't
know if anybody's noticed but I am
looking rather slender these days and do
you think it has anything to do with
your intramural alumni basketball league
that started no I think it has to do
with the fact that I'm eating far less
but after doing very limited physical
activity over the last six months I've
I've Doven Devon
I dived no it's dived but past tense
Doven what are you trying to say I've
Doven head deep
interesting right I've dived head deep I
dived head deep previously what you know
what I mean
English no I'm just saying Doven
what
I've Doven head deep
intense let's head deep isn't that you
dive head first I think it's head deep
no what the hell is head deep
oh I've Dove head first is it not sure
no keep just get the sentence out
into basketball again most of you don't
know but I am just an unbelievable
player I wouldn't say you're an
unbelievable player I would say you're
an unbelievable shooter yeah Ben's like
this you know firecracker you know they
should tossing the ball he's behind the
three and most of the time you hit those
threes really well but I've been to a
lot of your games and I always say like
if you were on my team I would hate you
you never run back to play defense I
guess I do you never pass you just wait
in like your spot for somebody to throw
you the ball and sometimes they do and
you shoot it but if not like you're
useless to the team and I think some of
the members of your intramural League uh
would agree with me well I went into an
intramural league today I have a charity
basketball tournament oh yeah I forgot
about tonight big Vision look it up
donate great cause uh and so like I'm
really just like playing a lot and then
all of a sudden I'm laying in bed and
I'm like holy [__] my whole body hurts
yeah my back my legs my arms yeah and
part of you thinks am I dying like is
this some kind of rare disease that has
all of a sudden entered my body like
that is making me like have atrophy and
lose everything and all of a sudden I'm
wasting away and you're just gonna wake
up and look next to me and I'm gonna be
dead but then
but then I remember that I'm playing
basketball and I haven't done that so
more likely than not the soreness is
coming from basketball not from a rare
disease you never know you never know
now let's dive in let's dove in first
that was so dumb what's wrong with it
was it no no no what about like there's
nothing with Doven let's dive into your
first game so I
I sometimes go to your intramural League
games because you know you guys are a
bunch of old guys and I think like oh
maybe some of the other wives will be
there where the [__] are these wives
nobody ever comes every time I go I feel
like such a loser I'm not coming anymore
like yeah where's the support there were
no wives everyone on your team is like
old and you guys lost because you were
playing to like a bunch of young guys
yeah so I figured like everyone on your
team has a wife or a girlfriend or
fiance and like where the hell were they
no clue they're not supportive therefore
I'm not supportive nowhere to be seen
nowhere to be seen but yes first game we
unfortunately lost we could have won we
should have won how much did you lose by
uh I think we ended up losing by 16 so
close at one point we were down by 30.
but then we had cut it to 10 and we were
right there we called the time out like
game plan we're like What do you say in
that huddle like are you the type of guy
who like inspires others or you get
inspired by another I would try I would
be the one inspiring but I'm not like as
you mentioned like a good enough
all-around player to really comment on
all facets of other people right you
can't say like Andrew do this correct
yeah you'd need the person who is a more
well-rounded player is able to opine on
others yes uh potential fall performance
performance exactly so no that's not me
I'm typically being spoken to and then I
will chime in and give like a good chant
yeah no like a good piece of advice and
then we'll all come out so we're down
ten we go into the Huddle we're like all
right we're right here we fought back
one play at a time let's just let's get
it done timeout's over go out all of a
sudden immediately somebody turns over
the ball they score turn over the ball
yeah well you took it down you took a
time out and you gave the young kids a
chance to like drink a Powerade and you
know maybe take an Adderall and of
course all I gotta say is that for an
intramural League yeah so unfair this
team none of their regular players first
of all none of them went to the school
neither did you yes but I've been
playing in it for 10 years oh wow I
can't believe you brought that up I
wasn't gonna bring it up but now that
you brought it up it's called the it's
called rail well Rama's alumni
intramural league ramaz is the school
that I went to right it is not the
school that Ben went to it's a school
that most of his friends went to and
they let him play in the league like 10
years ago so now he plays but for you to
sing for 10 years for you to sit there
and complain that members on the other
team are not alumni when you yourself
out and you're not even playing in your
own alumni League hell I am official
alumni I am they can't get their [__]
together they're literally the gym isn't
even open until mid-july the summer will
be over you I cannot believe you just
complain let me explain let me explain
there's a difference between not going
to the school but also not even being in
the league these kids none of them they
were all subs there was one kid one kid
on the team that was the representative
of that team
say something
I'm not sure who's on your team
but Andrew haft did not go to ramaz who
else is on your team Jordan okay Jordan
went to her must I don't remember the
others names but they're lovely and none
of them went to Ramos no no you are such
a hypocrite no but look listen to me you
took the what you took one thing he took
one thing okay fine finish your sentence
it's also about if you're in the league
or if you aren't right
there's Subs because everybody you know
is working and some nights you just
can't make of course of course so you're
allowed to pull a sub right and the sub
doesn't have to formally be in the
league
they just need to be friends with kids
that are in the league
this kid pulled five subs and all of the
subs were 20 21 years old my God could
they leap yeah it was just they were too
fast so we were too slow who's the best
player on your team
that game probably me oh my God no I'm
I'm serious no for real who's probably
me it should it should be Andrew yeah
you think he would admit Andrew stank it
up I think he would admit that that game
it was probably me and I wasn't that
great either I can tell you by far
Jordan Jordan was right I need to talk
to the other members on your team to
just kind of verify if you were in fact
the best player because you come home
from golf and you you're like oh my God
I crushed it and then no I will also
come home from golf and tell you that I
played terribly yeah but like our
gaslighting this entire Community I'm
just like I don't think you're an
accurate like representative you're not
an accurate historian to retell the
story of what happened on Monday night
it's possible that I am a bit jaded yeah
no and like of course like you should
think you're the best you are the best
no I know I'm just saying like in
reality I think in reality for that game
I was probably the best okay how many
points did you score nine nine twelve
nine nine maybe twelve yeah okay so it's
nine it's twelve it's three you know I'm
just saying we only scored 36.
how bad could it be how many did the
other score team score 79. not like
maybe like 70. well I'll be sure to keep
all the toasters abreast on the comings
and goings of your intramural League
because it's honestly hilarious what a
term abreast a breast I'm just saying
like you know actually we had a deer
toasters yesterday that really stumped
Jackie and I
um I'd like to hear your take on it if
you don't mind please so a girl had
written in that you know she has a
boyfriend who she loves whatever and he
opened up to her that he's really
self-conscious about his nipples he has
like puffy nipples and you know I
actually had heard of that before it's
like not the craziest you see that no he
just has puffy nipples yeah he's like a
skinny right you know what's he ever fat
no I'm sure she didn't bring it up and I
think it would have been relative but it
doesn't matter okay but he has puffy
nipples okay I don't know there's a huge
difference if you are just like a skinny
man born skinny always skinny and you
have puffy nipples I'm sorry yeah like
that's that's bad like you don't you
don't deserve that yeah but plenty of
formerly fat people turn skinny we'll
just keep the nipples from their past
I'd like to remind them that they were
once fat let's say for argument sake
like wait wasn't an issue okay so he's
always been skinny in his puffy nipples
yeah and it really got to a point
recently where it started bothering him
so he found these like bandages that you
put on and it really makes your nipples
look normal in shirts ah so she's so
happy for him but when they're being in
when they're like getting intimate
um he has to like kind of rip them off
before they start and it's like really
ruining the moment for her and like the
mood and she's like do I bring it up to
him or do I just like what do I do and
we were really stumped because like you
know her sexuality is you know a
priority but if she says to him like you
know you ripping off your nipple
bandages like is really a turn off this
guy who's just been open and vulnerable
about something he's self-conscious
about like will that crush him
so my advice was to get over it Jackie's
advice was to like busy herself while
he's taking off the nipple bandages you
know like maybe light a candle maybe you
know suggest shower sex so that before
you even get in the shower he has to rip
the Band-Aids off but I'm curious what
you think what your take is
I don't know enough about the specifics
with these nipple bandages like no no
I'm not talking about the specifics of
his history with okay with weight
fluctuations I'm talking about the
nipple bandages themselves as I think
about
ripping off a nipple bandage that makes
it seem like it's a significant adhesive
yeah
that would only make the nipples more
puffy So eventually he's going to have
like one of the longest nipples like
ever because you're just slowly ripping
ripping ripping ripping ripping no Ben
facts so one I think that you should
bring up if it's really that series of
an adhesive that you don't think that
this is the best solution for the
problem because you love him and want
him to always feel confident and you
don't want his nipples to get puffier
from there you can transgress to
recommending nipple surgery is that the
right word transition not transgress you
can transition into transition to
talking about nipple surgery if this is
something that bothers him enough just
do quick snip snip I'm sure it's like an
easy solve it's like a breast reduction
yeah exactly deep puff them yeah or
maybe if you use an ice roller
skinny company confidential yeah you
should use it for puffy nipples but I I
think like that's like a good right I
mean I don't know if like we need to
jump to surgery but I do think your
point about perhaps is not being the
best course of action I'm saying that's
the easiest way for her to bring it up
because she's bringing it up not because
it's something that's not sexy to her in
the bedroom but she's bringing it up
because out of concern out of concern
for him no that's good and it's valid so
I would go that route and also now that
I'm thinking about it
is this that common of a problem there
so I think like or is it like be or is
like boob tape for girls that he's just
using for his nips no so I actually
there is like a male condition
where we're not about weight where you
have like almost like breasts kind of
you have like a you have a puffy breast
I have a puffy nipple too yeah but
you're saying it say it
sure okay because yours is so clearly
associated with your weight
when your weight fluctuates so do your
breasts so people some people literally
have it's I don't know what it's called
I think it starts with a g it's like an
actual male condition
and I believe that's what this young
gentleman has I'm sure he's
self-conscious about it which is why I
told her just to get over it no no he's
got to fix it otherwise he'll always be
self-conscious about it yeah I also
would like to know the physical physique
of this man I know we spoke about the
weight piece but is he in the gym like
is he lifting because I think that puffy
nipples can be
just like
strong past weight training you'd think
or go to a doctor don't I
in closing don't put a strong adhesive
on a puffy nipple and then rip them off
every night after bed you're just going
to make them longer and then you're
gonna have to tuck them into your shoes
in closing
that was funny you know we're gonna get
into stories and um
before we do I just want to really
commend you you know you're really
you're a podcaster now yes how long have
you been doing good guys now has it been
a year no coming up on a year no okay
nine months that's coming up on a year
eight months that's coming up in a year
okay
um you are so
like every time we podcast together you
get so much better like you're being so
funny thank you very much I can't
recommend good guys enough I talk about
good guys all the time if you guys don't
know my husband Ben hosts a podcast on
our podcast Network called Good Guys
with Ben zoffer and Josh Peck Josh Peck
who we all know and love former Vlog
Squad member cast member of the iconic
hit show Drake and Josh she's now in How
I Met Your Father and you guys are just
like two Jewish Kings you sit around and
talk about food and I love it I listen
every week thank you and you're really
you're becoming so much more of a
skilled podcast host thank you very much
and I love having you thank you for
being here I appreciate it and yes good
guys is really fun we have a lot of
interesting guests on too you got a big
one coming up we do we do have a really
really big one uh which I'm excited
about can't talk about but we just had
Sophia Franklin on she was really fun
you guys you had Hilary Duff Ben had
Tana Mojo they literally get like such
things John Stamos because like Josh is
like really part of like the Hollywood
network no I mean Josh literally could
just like Snap his fingers and get an
amazing guess no it's so true yeah and
like it's it's huge it's huge it's huge
you guys really are you know you both
bring something to the table you bring
your puffy nipples exactly and he brings
Hollywood guests but our one-on-one
episodes are really great too so if you
haven't listened to Good Guys give it a
shot go back they do video go to Josh's
YouTube channel yes Josh Peck's YouTube
channel is where you can find our videos
um shallowing yeah anything else you
want to say or kind of defend yourself
on you know I come on this podcast on a
daily and talk about our marriage and I
think maybe sometimes you feel like I'm
not giving you a fair treatment so is
there anything you want to come on and
defend yourself I haven't really heard
anything recently that has made me fired
up
um so if there's anything that you want
to make me aware of that you've been
saying uh well we did have a
conversation about pizzagate
yeah i s there's this is again like just
like a non-issue okay you said I want
pizza I said I don't want to have pizza
you said but I really want pizza will
you have some pizza and it's like if I'm
trying not to eat pizza and you're
trying to force me to eat pizza is that
a good friend okay again that would
happen a good friend
like me we'll say okay I'll have the
pizza so a good friend will lie because
I knew that you just wanted a slice
anyways and what's the difference we
ordered the pizza you had your slice I
didn't have my slice that's it okay
that's not what happened but sure
sure
are you ready I'm ready all right let's
dive into the past five stories that you
need to know
go
I'm waiting
for what for crunch you have to do the
crunch yeah but it's to take about it no
we don't do that anymore you don't oh
I'm living in the past yeah okay I'll do
it again right yeah here are the past
five stories that you need to
I didn't say it
no
oh God totally botch at puffy nipples
today's episode is brought to you by
Sundays for dogs Sundays is healthy it
is air dried dog food made from a short
list of human grade ingredients Sundays
was co-founded by Dr Tory a practicing
veterinarian and it contains 90 Meat 10
vegetables and zero percent synthetic
nutrients so besides USDA beef and all
natural chicken you will find digestive
AIDS like pumpkin and Ginger and also
disease fighting antioxidants dog
parents report noticeable Health
improvements in their pups including
softer fur fresher breath better poops
and more energy dogs love Sundaes there
are so many benefits if you've been
thinking about investing in more healthy
fresh food to just make your stress bro
happy or healthier shinier better breath
check out Sundays for dogs so it's super
convenient because unlike other fresh
dog food it is zero prep zero mess and
zero stress it is shelf stable so it
makes it easy to feed your pup to top
quality food every order ships right to
your door so you'll never need to worry
about running out of food ever again
Sundays is also affordable it costs 40
percent less Us and other Healthy dog
food brands and that's because Sundays
does not waste their money shipping
Frozen packages instead they spend on
what matters which is sourcing the best
all natural ingredients for your little
streice bro so we've worked out a
special deal for our dog loving
listeners get 35 off your first order
when you go to sundays4dogs.com toast or
you can just use code toast to check out
that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash toast upgrade your pup to Sundaes
and feel good about the food you're
feeding your dog
today's episode is also brought to you
by Sephora we all know and love Sephora
it is the go-to place for beauty and it
is also the go-to place for clean Beauty
so Jax has you know been on this health
clean girly kick and she's actually
really got me inspired especially about
things that I put in my face like so
close to my eyes my nose my mouth my
ears all my orifices and Sephora makes
it so easy they have a clean Beauty Tab
and I was so excited to learn that so
many of the products that I already use
are clean Beauty like I love house Labs
I use a lot of their lip products I love
their blush clean Beauty milk milk
makeup I use so many milk makeup
products especially the hydro grip
primer clean don't we love to see it
Merit beauty is another brand that
Jackie loves that I actually knew about
first because of tick tock um and
they're a clean Beauty brand so it was
such a relief to see so many brands that
I already know and love being clean
Beauty but then also finding out new
brands that I hadn't heard of yet that I
could try that are clean Beauty so if
you want to learn more you can go to
sephora.com clean check out all their
clean products all the brands that you
can discover are already clean or trying
out new brands that aren't that you
didn't know that were clean but that are
and Sephora's just a number one spot for
anything beauty related so if you're a
clean beauty girl or if you're wanting
to get you know transitioned into more
clean beauty products Sephora is the
place to go it's so easy to shop it's so
fun to shop so if you want to learn all
about the clean makeup brands at Sephora
head over to sephora.com clean to learn
more visit sephora.com clean
okay are you ready for our first story
um a little sports news but it's like
sports Real Housewives adjacent so it's
really perfect for us Marcus Jordan is
defending his girlfriend Larsa Pippin
against accusations of her being a gold
digger Larson Pippen and her boyfriend
Marcus Jordan appeared on an upcoming
episode of a page six podcast during
which the couple dispels myths about
their headline-making relationship
including speculation that the reality
TV star is gunning for the Jordan family
fortune so
this is what Larsa said I feel like the
money thing is annoying and then he said
yeah I feel like people try to say Lars
is a gold digger and she's after the
Jordan family money or something
um she's such an independent career
driven women woman she's got it going on
it's the one comment or commentary that
I've got to refrain from commenting back
on okay so I actually don't think Larks
is a gold digger like if you watch Real
Housewives you know she literally makes
like millions of dollars a month on only
fans she's also like a successful
reality star she has a jewelry line like
I think she's doing fine and she
actually just actually recently filed
finalized her divorce from Scottie
Pippen they actually you know this whole
time weren't legally divorced I didn't
and on this real season season of Real
Housewives of Miami she signs the uh the
paperwork but her and Scotty have like
an amazing relationship she
they still have young kids she's doing
fine financially I'm sure Scotty and she
married Scotty way before
and I don't believe they had a prenup I
was gonna say I don't understand there
are a lot of things that you could call
her in this situation yeah gold digger
doesn't really make sense to me because
it's also assuming that Michael Jordan
who is just known as being not only like
the fiercest competitor on planet Earth
but somebody that is very protective of
his money like his money's his money
yeah why the hell would that be lars's
money yeah no like it like Larsa should
know that in all likelihood she marries
Michael's son and there is a monster
prenup yeah like there's not like she's
gold digging to a rich guy's son like
can't be the first person like that she
would think of yeah that's just that's
just not the right person to gold dig
from and I really think like at its core
like Larsa does not need money like I
think Larsa is extremely well off sure
but I'm saying regardless even if she
wasn't she would be bucking up that
accusation doesn't make any sense but I
do feel like this relationship is so
weird I was gonna say you could say that
they're headline hunting yeah you could
say that they're looking to be in the
news PR able stir up some drama because
there is there are literally seven
billion people on Earth that would be
less weird to date than Michael Jordan's
son right
they even meet well they're in the
basketball world like the fact that they
they know by the way they've probably
met like four years I'm sure they've
known each other since he was a kid
which makes it even weirder her
ex-husband
and his dad are what teammates legendary
teammates right from the Bulls yeah
that's like the documentary we need the
flu yeah we need the flu well that's one
Flu Game yeah yeah but like that was the
team yeah six championships that's weird
yeah so like it's very possible like
when celebrating one of the
Championships Marcus Jordan was like 11
maybe even younger right how old is he I
don't know but yes how many years ago
did they win the uh champ the last
championship I think 96
Marcus Jordan is 32 years old so how
many years ago shut up how many years
ago did they win he was like six that's
disgusting like that's what really
everyone should be talking about not the
gold digging and so I'm sure they
celebrated I'm floored he's 32 and how
old is larkside I believe she's about
50. which it doesn't sound no no the the
problem again is not the difference in
age it's the difference in age to when
they definitely met right okay ready
here so she's 48 he's 32. that's really
not that crazy no in nor in in normal
life it's not that crazy but in 1997 yes
which is when they won the championship
the last one okay 97.
she was married to Scotty yes they got
married that year yes so how old would
that make
if he's 32. how if he's 32 and that's 25
years ago and that was 26 years ago
he was six he was six
yeah
yeah and she definitely met him yeah
because they were celebrating right
families kids and Wives come yep
that's weird
that is what's weird and there were so
many rumors about their relationship and
for like like a year ago and they were
like no we would never like we're just
friends and now they're out here like
promoting a podcast they're fully like
not engaged sorry they're fully engaging
in a relationship so they like lied and
what does he do that's an amazing
question
I'm sure he like runs some sort of like
family business
Marcus Jordan job
I was a basketball player oh
he went to University of Central Florida
well he's not a currently current
basketball player because he's 32 and I
don't think he plays
he went to UCF yeah
um
he discontinued the game in 2012 and
then went to graduate with a degree in
Hospitality management so now oh cool so
maybe he's a restaurateur
perhaps
unclear what is clear is that Larsa
Pippen Is Not Gold Digging yeah yeah
but I don't entirely understand what she
is doing me neither but now they have a
podcast together they're kind of like us
like two you know podcasters in love
they're just like us we're the same
we're the same as them 100 I mean you
are three years older than me two
I don't know I'm 28 and you're like
another week yeah shut up you're 20
you're 31 and I'm 28 so I think my math
that's three years yeah but like for
another week yeah no because I'm 28 I'm
so young for like another
three weeks yeah because I'm 28.
it's true you're kind of like cradle
robbing kind of like I did cradle Rob
yeah big time you were like a big when I
was two and a half I came in with my big
nips
you definitely had big nips as a baby
for sure all right should we get into
some more lover news sure Shakira has
found herself in a messy love triangle
with two A-list celebrities Lewis
Hamilton and Tom Cruise who appears to
be losing clearly so as you know she's
now single she uh had a very bitter
divorce from her ex
um
Gerard Peak who's a bar a player for
Barcelona soccer
so now the singer has been spotted with
Lewis Hamilton on a number of occasions
but it also looks as though Hollywood
actor Tom Cruise could also be a dating
option for Shakira amid rumors that they
have met another a number of times so
Lewis Hamilton and Shakira were seen on
a boat together at the Miami Grand Prix
they went to dinner together at his
house in Barcelona last weekend they
were also seen partying together at a
bunch of different places so they're
understood to be like having like a fun
and flirty moment
um but the mission impossible actor is
also reportedly in the picture Tom was
flirting with the colombian-born singer
before she started dating Lewis Hamilton
and is now said to be frustrated with
having discovered that she is also
dating F1 Legend Lewis Hamilton the
Hollywood actor Tom Cruise believed that
he had incredible chemistry with shapira
shapira
[Music]
I call okay sorry never mind with
Shakira I was gonna say Shapiro of
course with Shakira he had incredible
chemistry and taking it as a slam dunk
that they'd be dating in no time his
close pal has confirmed that the
doctor's ego has been dented after
hearing that Shakira had rejected his
advances and instead chosen a potential
romance with
Tom Cruise's actual friend Lewis
Hamilton
who where was that article written
everywhere but I took it from the mirror
they had the best like I'm more just
curious like who who did Tom Cruise talk
to those are like some big quotes yeah
it was from a friend of his but it was
picked up everywhere and you know what
like there were rumors like a little
while ago that Shakira and Tom Cruise
were like seen out together yada yada
and then very quickly she's like
everywhere with Lewis Hamilton who's a
much better match for her body for sure
um and I'm sure Tom Cruise is like I'm
the big man in Scientology like Tom
Cruise in his own mind is a legend you
know he's like the number one guy in
Scientology in the real world he's like
short and old and I don't think he's
really that hot except for like his
money if I'm being honest interesting um
you don't no moving career
what no movie career no movie career
like you don't like you just think of
Tom Cruise as Scientology yeah
interesting
yeah I think we I think and I think we
all should okay he's like a deeply
problematic person
so having said that I'm sure Shakira you
know she her ex cheated on her and it
was like this big messy divorce so I'm
sure she immediately just like wanted to
be outspotted with like famous people to
like rub it in his face and like get her
groove back so I'm sure someone was like
yeah Tom Cruise wants to go on a date
with you she's like yeah sure whatever
so it'll be clear Top Gun nothing no
like top gun's cool but like Tom Cruise
is like a short King he's like deeply
entrenched in a lot of problematic
behavior when it comes to Scientology
he's like the number one funder of
Scientology like is he yeah he's like
the president and CEO
he's responsible for getting like so
many celebrities involved like he's so
problematic
sounds like a good recruiter yeah so
having said that I'm sure Shakira went
and like it was fine and he thought like
I want to find my next Queen my Reyna
you know that's probably what he thought
and then she was like okay this guy's a
freak and Lewis Hamilton was an option I
just feel like Lewis Hamilton and her
are so much better match for sure like
in every way in every way agreed and
they're on the same level like she's
really a global Superstar he is really
like a global Superstar it's just like
is this did this loose-lipped friend of
Tom Cruise also mentioned that he
thought that they were exclusive it
sounds like Tom Cruise you know he's old
school he's 60. he went out like maybe
on a date and he's 60. really yeah look
great in Top Gun he did
um 60. Tom Cruise is 60 Lewis Hamilton
is 38 and Shakira is 46. so she's right
in the middle of them so of course she's
gonna feel like going to go for like the
younger more famous like Global
Superstar yeah it's like not even sure
um but I'm sure Tom Cruise is like
crying in his Hollywood Mansion he's
used to everyone in in Scientology just
like yes sir yes sir yes sir and you
know what I can't imagine anyone in the
world would want to go on a date with
Tom Cruise after he see after they see
like what it's like for Nicole Kidman
and Katie Holmes they were both married
to Tom Cruise
you know that Nicole Kidman and Tom
Cruise have kids together okay they were
born into Scientology
Nicole Kidman was in Scientology and she
I think came came to the conclusion on
her own that this was a severely [__]
up cult and she left and her children
still do not speak to her really because
you become an SP shunned person wow yeah
they don't talk to her holy crap and
then and then you know she's terrible
she's married to Keith Urban yeah Keith
Urban writes a song you know what kind
of man doesn't let his son see his
mother you know it's like it's a whole
thing wow and then Katie Holmes was with
him had a kid Surrey Cruz born into
Scientology Katie Cruz had to get out
she got her and Surrey they both got out
oh they both thank God yeah they're nice
and now that we're kind of having like a
Renaissance of Katie home she's like she
took a lot of time off she did not like
the public eye and now she's like out
and about she was dating this guy like
I'm happy for Katie Holmes good yeah so
I can all set to say I'm sure you know
Shakira went out with Tom Cruise because
it sounded like a fun idea she took one
look around and was like I'm out of here
[__] as you say it doesn't sound like a
fun idea she clearly didn't have all the
information that you had she clearly
didn't watch Leah remini's a e special
on Scientology I clearly didn't either
you didn't oh my God it's crazy they
like hunt her down I think maybe I
watched like a little bit of it it's
really good but then you finished it
yeah you know it's called um there's a
few but the good one is on HBO called
going clear going clear means you know
the in Scientology you have to like pay
it's like literally a cult and you like
join a level and you pay and you keep
going up levels levels of the sea org
that's what it's called you have to pay
for each level yeah it's like fraudulent
oh that's crazy and when you get to like
the highest level which very few people
do it's called going clear you've like
reached pink existence and that's what
freaks like you know John Travolta and
Thomas also money all money it's it's
really a money thing in at every level
you pay more money but it's a religion
so it's like a tax-exempt money thing
it's like a it's a pretty good scheme
they got going very interesting yeah but
like people go missing if you keep up
with Leah Remini on Twitter Twitter
Shelley miskiva miscavage she's like you
know the wife of one of the head guys
and she's been missing for six years oh
man it's very dark so all that to say I
don't know if Tom Cruise is that
eligible as of a bachelor yeah I can't
imagine that being something you want to
get into no
are you ready for our next story yes we
had some love news now we have some
bitter divorce news so you know our King
John Dutton Kevin Costner yes is going
through a bitter divorce terrible and
who divorced too
I think she was the one who filed but
that doesn't really mean anything yeah
but you know it's having an effect on
Yellowstone he hasn't showed up for
filming in like months really he's so
sad you know the season we most recently
watched of course they took like a
mid-season finale
oh my forgot they still haven't filmed
that second half of the season because
he won't show up he won't show up
there's like a lot of things we don't
actually know what's going on they
haven't said anything but I do believe
it's pretty much confirmed that this
will be the final season um just when we
started watching it I love that show but
you know they have all the other shows
1883 1929. yeah you watch all of them
without me right yeah and they're doing
another one you knew how much I loved
Yellowstone you watch all them without
me they're doing two more that I'll save
for you because they're both linked to
Yellowstone the first is called the
sixes you know that farm where they sent
Jimmy yes so that that I have honestly
no interest oh I think the farm is
boring yeah because we don't know
anything about it no come on and that's
like the random Texas Farm where he
meets that woman in these milk and cows
yeah then there's another spin-off
coming with Matthew McConaughey which
sounds good yeah all right all right all
right but so here's the details of Kevin
Costner's divorce his ex-wife or
whatever you want to call her
we got the Daily Mail like move I can't
see the headline
we should kill them
no like okay estranged I literally can't
I have to sneeze sneeze
somebody that needs to sneeze Kevin
Costner is a strange estranged wife
Christine oh my God remains at their 145
million dollar Coastal California
compound as she refuses to leave the
property after following uh the divorce
filing in violation of their prenup So
Christine Baumgardner she was the one
who filed for divorce from Kevin Costner
last month the actor is now saying that
she has remained in his home to persuade
him to give in to various Financial
demands he said he has given her a
million 1.45 million dollars to relocate
under the prenup terms that they agreed
to
so the oscar-winning actor has this
prenup that basically says she has a
30-day period to move out of the house
that he owns but she ain't leaving she's
using it as leverage like [__] you want
me out I want more because in their
prenup it says he'll give her 1.45
million dollars to relocate which I
don't know you can't really go from
living in a 150 million dollar house to
1.4 million dollars 150 million that's
how much their house that I think that's
like their main house in California
sorry if you read that I was trying to
sneeze but yeah you said why don't you
just go sneeze and any anybody know
everybody knows that if you say to
somebody that's trying to seize just
sneeze they won't sneeze and now I have
the sneeze stuck in me and it will never
come out again okay your life is so 150
million dollar main house and in
Montecito and the prenup says here's one
and a half million dollars go [__]
yourself right like you have to go leave
my house yes and go find a studio
accommodation sure okay yeah they live
in a 150 million dollar house in
Montecito yeah and she won't leave and I
kind of love that for her
what do you do with 150 million dollar
house I just want to say something kind
of crazy I don't want it is that what
you were going to say too big no too big
that's the thing Montecito is a very you
know expensive area I'm going to show
you this house it's from an aerial view
you would think it's like this palatial
estate with acres and acres and Acres
it's a beach house so you know beach
houses especially in California are all
lined up next to each other that's the
house
does that look like my 150 million
dollar house
no I know isn't that shocking it looks
like 12. yeah
it's like super close to the two houses
next to it it's like a classic beach
house I mean he has beach access and he
has Beach views which makes it you know
a more valuable property 150 million is
that crazy I don't believe it I think
yeah I think they took the wrong picture
no there's literally a million pictures
of this house
this doesn't look that big if you had
150 million dollars like what kind of
property are you buying first oh I was
gonna say I'm not buying a property
I'm buying 10. but where like you're
gonna do a mountain house a beach house
Mountain House and a beach house and a
city house
and an international house
where International such a good question
probably like bvis something like that
or all the wealthy people or Turks Turks
um maybe something in Israel
only with 150 million dollars to spend
on real estate you're going to put into
one house I know I mean I think Kevin
Costner has way more than 150 million
dollars he also has this incredible
estate and I believe in Colorado that's
very yellow Stony and at first when they
were getting divorced that house was
like the scene of the crime and now she
won't leave that one it's just so weird
yeah I feel like Kevin Costner is like
going through some sort of midlife
crisis because he's kind of being a dick
he's not showing up for work he's
kicking his wife who probably you know
they have three kids one the youngest I
think is 13. so it was probably you know
taking care of the kids he's kicking her
out you know he's kind of being a dick I
feel like he's going through some sort
of midlife crisis like he was really
really famous when he was young then I
feel like he you know became like a
legend but not you know A-list and now
he's become a list again now he's become
A-list again in the last five years
because of yeah and I think he's
becoming like a diva again that's kind
of what I'm getting and maybe Christine
you know they they met at you know when
he was kind of being Hamish and and down
to earth and now she's seeing it inside
of him she doesn't like and perhaps
that's why she followed that's kind of
how I feel you know I married you before
good guys it's true and now you have
this like big and I definitely think
that like you think you're too good for
me I mean it's literally how I feel I
met you when you had literally nothing
and I'm the same [__] I was oh please I
am no whatever no you're definitely
different oh I am yeah good guys has
changed you interesting so has Spritz
you just kind of like I think you think
you've surpassed me like you're ready
for your next wife no I mean
that's just like not true I think it is
no I think it is I do think though that
I am much funnier than you give me
credit for
who I was saying this to and I think
I've said this to you before
it's such a shame that you decided to
marry me
because if you married anyone else
you would immediately be like the
funniest guy in every room but you're
really just like irrelevant when I'm in
the room I am still the funniest person
in all these rooms even the rooms that
I'm in yeah
you are a more traditi you are a more
pub I could never do stand up I'm just
saying in the room quick jokes
that's me bro
that's me maybe and if you had married a
simple girl Katie you know it's very
It's a Wonderful Life
but then I'm bored I know I'm saying I'm
not saying you should marry someone else
I'm down I'm just saying like had you
married someone else oh my God it would
be like that guy Ben he's so funny she
wouldn't get my jokes she wouldn't get
your jokes I get your jokes
but if you were to marry someone else I
wouldn't what would you be looking for
in a partner
hairy white
a little bit a little bit brown white
and brown
great at licking oh
Theo yes I was like what are you saying
I'm like are you calling me Harry I
think the word you meant was furry Harry
he's Harry right and brown I was like
what the [__] that's a good one I know
because I'm funny because you are funny
yeah what are you hysterical today's
episode is brought to you by Lululemon
specifically Lululemon shorts it's that
time of year we are bearing our legs and
you want to do it in the best and the
best when it comes to shorts is
Lululemon they were made to stretch flex
and support the infinite ways of working
out giving you the courage to LEAP into
something totally new and unexpected so
here are some of our favorite shorts
from Lululemon a total brand that you
could trust when it comes to workout
wear whether you're wearing it to work
out or just like run to the grocery
store so the hottie hot short is the
short with a comfortable range of motion
and a flattering fit the hottie hot
short allows you to Max your stride so
you can move freely with confidence the
lightweight Swift fabric lets in airflow
so you can move without baggage it's
designed to Wick away sweat before you
even notice it's there you carry your
Essentials with two perfectly placed
discrete pockets that's the best part I
love having Pockets but I hate when they
like bulge out and like make you look
like ugly they also have the Wonder
train short which is the best seller of
theirs it's the short with supportive
stretch that also keeps you dry it's
powered by everlux fabric the Wonder
train collection manages to keep heat
and sweat away so you stay comfortable
and focused sweat wicking and quick
drying material is of utmost importance
during this warm season we've got
crevices that we need to keep dry and
Lululemon is keeping that top of mind
also with Father's Day coming up they
have a lot of great men's shorts the
pace breaker short is one of their best
it's a versatile short that's up to any
challenge get into the Lululemon shorts
at lululemon.com that's
l-u-l-u-l-e-m-o-n.com check out all
their shorts it's that time of year you
guys make sure you've got your
undercarriage your nether regions taken
care of with Lululemon today's episode
is also brought to you by codery how
many times do you get up in the middle
of the night to change your baby's
diaper if you have a little one it's
probably been a while since you went a
full night without interruptions but
that's that's where codery diapers come
in cotery diapers are designed for a
better sleep and have given Jax an extra
one to three hours of sleep per night
you know when it comes to our baby and
their bottoms we want the best of the
best and if you need more sleep as a
parent if you're exhausted check out
cautery diapers cotery diapers are
designed to minimize leaks blowouts
we've all been there and diaper rash so
you and your baby can enjoy more
comfortable dry interrupted sleep they
have up to 70 percent more liquid
capacity and they absorb up to four
times faster by moving liquids away from
Skin Within 15 seconds so it keeps your
baby drier than the leading diaper brand
which can bring you a lot of Peace of
Mind whether you're a parent an auntie
who really cares and gets in the weeds
if you're an auntie who gets down and
dirty with the diapers why don't you
suggest codery Jackie's been having
codery at her house here and in Florida
for a few weeks I know she loves them
and they really do have a much better
like better drying effect and much
better for nighttime specifically
they've been awarded bestdiper by
parents.com and by baby list and codery
products are fragrance free
hypoallergenic made with responsibly
sourced plant-based materials all while
feeling as soft as cashmere on your
Bebe's bottom it's time to use a better
diaper and right now corduroy is
partnering with our podcast to offer you
20 off your first subscription order
plus free shipping at codery.com promo
code toast that's codery spelled
c-o-t-e-r-i-e.com promo code toast for
20 off your first subscription order and
free shipping codery.com promo code
toast all right I want to get into this
Jeopardy story that um people are like
quaking over so there was like a
Jeopardy clue given a few nights ago on
Jeopardy and people on the internet were
like freaking out that the person didn't
know this answer to the riddle and I
have the riddle and I just want to say I
don't know the answer and I don't think
it's that crazy that that person didn't
know the answer and I'm curious if you
know the answer before you go into that
how do you not keep switching this is
one thing about podcasting that I just
can't do I can't sit without switching
legs crossing differently or moreover
cross switch legs
um I've crossed and uncross my legs like
four times I just don't talk about it so
that's why it's not a big deal oh you
have yeah you can keep moving your legs
nobody cares nobody cares quite
literally nobody cares unless your shoe
is in my frame like we won't get any
comments about me moving my legs well
now we will because you brought it up
interesting
you want to cut that out no okay all
right ready for this Jeopardy Saga sure
one seemingly simple answer prompt has
gotten three Jeopardy contestants in hot
water with fans as they failed to
correctly finish the Lord's Prayer the
clue that had all three contestants
stumped was Matthew 6 9 says Our Father
which art in Heaven this be thy name
art father
art Our Father Who Art in Heaven blank
be thy name
Our Father Art in Heaven blank let be
thy name no Our Father which art in
Heaven blank be thy name
God
I would have said like he he I knew it
started with an H but like I don't know
it's like
something like that the answer is
hallowed
and I think it's a part of like a very
common kind of popular basic
oh New Testament Vibe was the person a
new testament reader well there were
three contestants and nobody knew it and
people on Twitter like were how can all
three adults who made it to contestants
on this show not know at least the start
of the Lord's Prayer because maybe it's
not their lord yeah like maybe they're
Jewish or Indian or Muslim like
literally anything like not you being
so
inclusive yeah I mean like
the book I've read no say sorry and by
the way they have sorry Matt they have
religious
um
categories all the time and some of them
are Jewish and like people don't know it
and I obviously do like it's not a big
deal no I don't know it no and honestly
I feel like the Jewish ones are the
easiest ones because if you're Jewish
and if you're like Christian or Catholic
you know Old Testament for sure it's
included in your required reading as
well yeah Matt is exclusive yeah we
don't know Matt nope we don't see Matt
I've never I'm sorry to this man I don't
know who this man is I don't know Matt
so I didn't think it was that crazy I
it's not I just think it really shows
how Anglo-Saxon our culture is
um
but there have been like Crazier by the
way who do you think is going to replace
Pat Sajak me I said this to you yeah
when I make a great Wheel of Fortune
host give us a audition
and now let's spin the wheel
you literally look like a pedophile
that's all I got that wasn't very good
no and that's not even what Pat says and
tonight we are giving away one new Jeep
Cherokee Cherokee no no that's also not
what he says okay it's not like his
classic zingers what's the classic I
don't know Pat Sajak's classic zingers
all right we got a phrase up on the
board Sally you're first oh that was
good that was good but now there's Sally
there's always a contestant one of them
could be named oh yeah yeah no Banner
yeah she's still there yes she's staying
I believe she stays she'll win I don't
know but she looks great no but I'm just
saying like Vanna and it's it's the two
of them I know she must be very upset at
him well their rumors are now that uh
Ryan Seacrest is in talks to take on
Wheel Of Fortune
I know it's like so uninspired like it
makes sense yeah especially because he
just gave up uh Live with Kelly so his
hosting Duties are like slimmed down he
has the radio show he has American Idol
I think he's exclusively doing things at
film in La now because he was going back
and forth between New York and L.A it
was like so toxic so I actually do think
he he has the the always Wheel of
Fortune filmed here no I think it's
filmed in L.A yeah yeah yeah hmm
but that's a job you have for life
and a good job yeah fun job high paying
job it should be Steve Harvey
it should be Steve Harvey the king of
game shows but this why I think Steve
Harvey and Ryan Seacrest are not the
right people for it is because they're
both known for so many other things
whereas Like Pat Sajak was The Wheel of
Fortune guy like you need a guy who
could commit his whole life or a girl
his whole life his whole career so you
want to know name not a no name but like
a professional host who maybe we've seen
before but whose whole thing now can be
Wheel of Fortune what about that guy
from that show that popped up during
covid that was like Scott Rogowski what
about him you know what else does he do
nothing
um and he is probably the my least
favorite person we've ever had on the
toast oh I forgot he was so rude to us
like he got so famous from HQ and it
clearly went to his head he was like
such a dick like he we literally started
asking him questions on the podcast and
he's like you guys are nervous around me
right you're like no what the hell we're
like you live in our phones what are you
talking about like calm down
um so I I think he burned fast and
bright you know yeah he's gone I think
he's gone
hmm I still vote Steve Harvey I think
it's a very good suggestion but imagine
how much more fun it would be I know the
way he could play with contestants but
the thing is he does that on Family Feud
and he does it so we should do it on
every show but he should also do How He
Wants To Be A Millionaire he should also
do Jeopardy he is game shows he is game
shows and if you don't watch The Game
Show Network you should you don't watch
a Game Show Network we have we have but
we don't even have the channel but we
should I didn't know you eliminated it I
did it we went on vacation like three
years ago and the TV like only had GSN
and we loved it love it we watched so
many they have on Game Show Network they
obviously have like Family Feud no they
also have a lot of like turnt games yeah
like weird ass [__] and oh you know who
hosts a lot of shows on GSN who would be
good for who Wants To Be A Millionaire
who you mean Wheel of Fortune yes wait
what is that guy's name he's in Pitch
Perfect he sits up at the mic with
Elizabeth Banks
Pitch Perfect he's like the MC do you
know what I'm talking about yes I do I
don't know his name though
okay okay his name is John Smith let me
see a picture of him again he hosts a
million shows on Game Show Network Yep
this guy hold on you love this guy
oh he would be great and he does game
show hosting you're right John Smith
would be great he would be great on
Wheel of Fortune but speaking of Pitch
Perfect I also think if they're looking
for a younger more famous host Adam
DeVine would also be a really good host
yeah but Adam Devine's really more of an
actor now I know but like he could do it
yeah he could I think he's so funny I
think he's a star he's great have you
seen his Netflix special no it was
pretty good yeah I'm happy you watch it
without me yeah
um all right ready for our Finland final
shorty shorty story it's a little
international finance and e-commerce
news not e-commerce international
finance news cool
Beyonce is to blame for inflation in
Sweden the 41 year old music icon kicked
off her Renaissance World Tour in
Stockholm Sweden on May 10th and it is
somewhat to blame for the rise of
inflation in the country according to
senior Economist and one of the top
Nordic Banks quote Beyonce is
responsible for the extra upside
surprise this month it's quite
astonishing for a single event we
haven't seen this before from April to
May monthly inflation in Sweden
increased 0.3 percentage points data
from statistics uh showed
excuse me partially due to a broad set
of goods and services for instance hotel
and restaurant visits and recreational
Services which include concert tickets
so Beyonce's started for World Tour in
Sweden seems to have colored May
inflation how much is uncertain but
probably between 0.2 and 0.3 percent
um that hotels and restaurants added
perhaps also hiked up concert tickets uh
concert ticket prices as well I mean
this is not shocking there's a few
concerts right now that are like
rattling
the local economy who wrote that up
this is like big news yeah I was just
talking about this with somebody else
last night the Taylor Swift is so
freaking famous and what she's doing is
so unbelievable that Beyonce's on tour
and nobody's talking about it I know
well the thing is is that Beyonce's tour
started internationally so she's been to
Sweden she's been to Paris so they're
probably talking about it there you
think so but when Beyonce comes here and
then I think they actually they plan
towards at the same time Taylor hasn't
gone International yet they're probably
gonna switch interesting and Beyonce's
tour will be like on the trip of
everyone and then when Taylor goes
abroad I think they spoke about it I
think they definitely maybe not like on
the phone to each other but I'm sure
their team's coordinated there's only so
many stadiums in America yeah and you
know Luke Holmes is on a stadium tour
now too and Morgan Wallen was but
canceled so there's only summer time is
a hard is a hard time to get booked at a
stadium Ed Sheeran is doing one too so
it was actually pretty smart of Beyonce
to start abroad so she can have her own
moment interesting cause if you're doing
a stadium tour right now no one's
talking about it because everyone's
talking about Taylor the inflation piece
though is interesting it makes perfect
sense for things like hotels well you
know obvious but somebody uh some
analyst did the data the Taylor Swift
era tour this summer will generate four
billion dollars for the economy wow you
know because everyone and and every time
Taylor goes to a city she's boosting
local restaurants local hotels local you
know shops it's been really good for the
economy and so all that together in
every four billion dollars added to the
economy that's insane but like back to
Beyonce in Sweden you're saying that
local restaurants are raising their
prices they're reprinting menus because
Beyonce is coming they're reprinting
menus yeah no you're saying that you
said that they're raising their prices
hotels it makes sense I didn't say
they're raising their prices Oh I
thought that's what you said no she's I
I said that ticket prices are probably
now hiked
but no just the local people flocking to
this town in Sweden
hitting up all the restaurants shopping
at all the shops I understand I okay
that is what's contributing and that's
why it makes sense there are very few
artists who like have such power that
they actually influence local economies
Beyonce is one of them and Taylor Swift
is definitely one of them that's why
free agency in sports is so interesting
because if the like when LeBron left
Cleveland their economy tanked really
yeah yeah for like a smaller town for a
smaller town yeah I'm sure like LeBron's
impact on La was much smaller and
different for sure impact if he had went
to like you know the Charlotte Bobcats
yeah absolutely and I'm sure it's the
same exact thing with Taylor Swift when
she came to MetLife it probably didn't
change right New York but when she went
to Glendale yeah yeah and she's going to
Pittsburgh this weekend are you going I
was thinking about it I've I've decided
no because nobody would come with me
it's just too far like do you think it's
Loki like so hard to get to from New
York even though on a map they're like
super close to each other the fact that
you came into our bedroom and said let's
go to Taylor Swift this weekend she's in
Pennsylvania and I'm here thinking like
New Hope I didn't say Pennsylvania you
keep I did not say Pennsylvania you did
I did not say Pennsylvania because I
think at my core I don't really even
know or acknowledge that Pittsburgh is
in Pennsylvania it's not it's don't
state right so I never would have said
that I said Pittsburgh it's so far like
I weirdly go there on every tour stop
because like the toast is huge in
Pittsburgh and it's low-key so
inconvenient like I never want to go
back there's so few flights but you have
to fly it's like an eight-hour drive
yeah it's far it's so bizarre well those
are the fast five stories we covered
Sports we covered Finance we covered the
economy what more could you ask for from
a bludgeon guange episode you couldn't
you couldn't and I couldn't ask for more
I'm so glad that we dove in head first
yeah Doven we dove in the head first no
we dove in was it headfirst what was the
other thing that I said head deep we
drove and head deep we don't get deep we
drove and head deep it doesn't even
sound like English yeah I'm sure that
you guys like don't even need to say
this because your podcast is just so
huge but like this is a five-star
episode I agree like give it five stars
no Jackie and I do acknowledge when we
think like an episode is like really
spectacular give the episode five stars
that's what I'm saying yeah share it
with a friend you should share it it
should be shared share away and while
you're at it share spread Society with a
friend Sports society.com Go toast a
little discount for the summer thank you
guys so much for listening to the toast
the millennial Morning Show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcasting we're
podcasts can be found so at Spotify
iTunes digital public radio I heart
radiocast box all the places baby listen
to podcast leave a five star review
about a beautiful stunning and wickedly
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing day tomorrow's episode is
Jackson Claude Audio Only so don't miss
it love you bye bye